Ich war voller Begeisterung.
Das ist wie Welt zusammen brechen.
Es war 6 Uhr 20 Morgens hier nach Deutschlandzeit.
Sehr, sehr, sehr deprimierend.
Der hat gewonnen.
Der ist unser Präsident für nächsten vier
Jahre.
Punkt.
Trump ist ungeeignet in dieser Rolle.
Ich konnte das nicht glauben.
Trump hat eigentlich gar nicht damit gerechnet,
dass er in dieses Amt kommt.
Das ist nicht leicht, von dem einen Tag in
den nächsten, hast du eine Million Mitarbeiter.
Trump hat ganz andere Erwartungen.
Ich weiß nicht welche Schule kann man diesen
Job lernen.
Der ist eine Fernsehfigur.
Das ist schlimmer geworden, als ich eigentlich
erwartete.
Das habe ich eigentlich befürchtet, mit seiner
Amtseinführung im Januar letztes Jahr.
Und die Erwartung war, dass schon schlimme
Sachen passieren.
Es ist tatsächlich passiert.
Ich bin begeistert, dass wir einen Präsidenten
haben, das put America first.
From this day forward it's going to be only:
America first, America first.
Ich sehe Trump als Präsident als Troublemaker.
Der ist ein Mann, der sagt, was er denkt.
Ist ungewöhnlihch.
Für einen Statesman.
Also was ich für einen Präsident er war
da, ob das Trump ist oder der nächste oder
der frühere, ist einfach, Intelligenz, einen
zeigen, dass man mit chaotischen Verhältnissen
zurecht kommt.
Nicht einfach nach Gefühl spontan reagieren.
Mein Wunsch ist, dass er weniger tweetet.
Das er ein bisschen erst mal überlegt, was
er sagt.
Die Konsequenzen dadurch hat.
Beispiele kommen immer wieder.
Wie unberechenbar er ist.
Und es spielt eine Rolle, was Leute im Kabinett
gewählt haben, aber seine Erfahrung ist weniger
Erfahrung zu regieren.
Moment die Wirtschaft in Amerika boomt.
Der Aktienmarkt ist auf höchsten Rekord.
Wo eigentlich die Demokraten gesagt haben,
dass wird größter Flop in der History.
Das ist nix passiert.
Das ist lächerlich.
Wie Trump sich anzieht.
Was er für eine Frisur hat.
Selber wahrscheinlich gefärbt.
Seine Gesichtfarbe.
Es ist eine komische Figur.
Aber es ist nichts mehr zu lachen.
Jeder hat seine Art.
Aber wie kann ich von seiner Haarfrisur beurteilen.
Es ist action.
Was er gemacht hat.
Seinen Händedruck finde ich harmlos.
Das ist seine Art jemanden seine Hand zu schütteln.
Amerikaner ist Händeschütteln nicht so wichtig.
Mein Blick auf Amerika hat sich schon verändert.
Also von Deutschland aus, vom Ausland aus,
sieht man das sowieso anders.
Mein Blick auf Amerika ist completly positive.
Ich sehe eigentlich schon seit Trump im Amt
ist, beziehungsweise schon seit der Wahlkampf,
dass Amerika mehr gespaltet ist.
Die Beziehung zwischen Deutschland das geht
weiter.
Autos werden verkauft.
Und unsere Hamburger.
Wir haben gerade einen neuen Hamburgerladen
aufgemacht.
Five Guys gerade in Frankfurt.
Und es ist voll.
Ich finde es toll.
Der Tourismus ist okay.
Leute warten immer noch vor unserem Konsulat
für Visas.
Beziehung ist super.
Teilweise ist es so extrem, dass die sagen
die würden eigenltich eine Reise absagen.
Die würden aus Protest nicht in die USA gehen.
Verstehe ich.
Amerika ist nicht Trump.
Das ist, was ich toll finde.
Amerika ist Amerika.
Wir sollten nie vergessen, dass Amerika die
Beziehung zwischen uns ist so stark.
Ein Trump in seinen vier Jahren kann das nicht
brechen.
Ich wurde eigentlich nie so richtig beschimpft.
Oder angespuckt oder so.
Weil ich Amerikanerin bin.
Mein Leben ist schwerer dadurch natürlich.
Das muss ich eigentlich sagen, dass in Deutschland
ist Obama fast übertrieben geliebt und ist
immer noch geliebt.
Das spielt eine große Rolle.
Das ist so eine krasser Unterschied jetzt.
Natürlich sehen die Deutschen das.